dividir entre 10 al igual que
multiplicar por 10 crea un patrón con
los números así que vamos a investigar
lo que pasa cuando dividimos entre 10 y
ver si podemos descubrir el patrón y tal
vez se relacione con el patrón que
resulta de multiplicar por 10 vamos a
comenzar con un ejemplo simple digamos
30 entre 10 y una manera de pensar en
esto es tomar el número 30 y dividirlo
en grupos de 10 entonces vamos a ver
cuántos grupos de 10 podemos sacar de 30
un grupo de 10 es 10 así que no es
suficiente un segundo grupo sería 20 más
un tercer grupo 30 así que podemos
pensar en 30 como 10 10 + 10 o tres
grupos de 10 entonces si dividimos 30
entre 10 si dividimos 30 en grupos de 10
terminaremos con tres grupos vamos a
hacer otro tal vez otro un poco más
difícil
digamos 110 entre 10
y cuando estamos dividiendo estamos
tomando 110 y lo estamos dividiendo en
grupos de 10 así que vamos a ver cuántos
grupos de 10 necesitamos para llegar a
110 tenemos 10 10 es 20 30 40 50 60 70
80 90 100 y 110 entonces esto que
tenemos aquí son los grupos de 10 que
necesitamos para llegar a 110 así que
vamos a ver cuántos grupos son 1 2 3 4 5
7 8 9 10 11 nuestra respuesta es 11 si
tenemos 110 y lo dividimos en grupos de
10 nos quedan 11 grupos vamos a revisar
estos ejemplos hagamos una pausa y
veamos si podemos ver un patrón 30
dividido entre 10 es igual a 3 110
dividido entre 10 es igual a 11 qué pasa
con el 30 y con el 110 para llegar a
estos cocientes lo que pasó fue que
quitamos el 0 que estaba al final del
número nuestra solución es el mismo
número pero sin el 0 que estaba al final
también en este caso la solución es el
mismo número pero sin el cero del final
y si recordamos el caso de la
multiplicación era opuesto si tenemos 2
por 10 en lugar de dividirlo si tenemos
2 por 10 el resultado es 20 o el 2 que
es nuestro número original con un cero
al final recuerda otro caso 13 por 10
es igual a 13 que es el número original
con un 0 que ponemos al final entonces
en la multiplicación cuando
multiplicamos por 10 agregamos un 0 al
final del número
y cuando dividimos hacemos lo opuesto le
quitamos un 0 al final del número así
que conociendo ese patrón hagamos otra
división tal vez una en la que no
podamos escribir todos los grupos de 10
pero tratemos de usar el patrón para
resolverla si tenemos algo como 7000
dividido entre 10 bueno nuestra solución
es 7.000 pero sin el cero del final
porque estamos dividiendo entre 10 así
que en lugar de tener 7000 tenemos 700
siete mil dividido en grupos de diez es
igual a 700 grupos de diez así que la
solución es de 700 vamos a ir un paso
más adelante y vamos a pensar en lo que
les está pasando a estos números cuando
los dividimos entre 10 al 30 al 110 al
7000 en términos de su valor posicional
aquí tenemos la gráfica de valor
posicional vamos a usarla para ver
algunos de los números que usamos antes
digamos 30 y cuando dividimos 30 entre
10 recuerda lo que pasa con el 3 en
lugar de ser 3 decenas
el resultado es 3 unidades el 3 se movió
a una posición en su valor posicional
hacia la derecha y el 0 en realidad
también lo hizo lo hizo hacia los
decimales lo que nos da como resultado
3.0 que es lo mismo que 3 y esa es la
razón por la que no necesitamos escribir
el 0 y por eso lo tache entonces nuestro
número en lugar de ser 3 decenas cuando
lo dividimos entre 10 se convierte en
tres unidades vamos a intentar hacer una
división un poco más difícil
lo hicimos con siete mil siete millares
cero centenas cero decenas cero unidades
y cuando dividimos entre diez nuestros
siete de la posición de los millares
pasó a ser un siete en la posición de
las centenas y el cero de las centenas
pasó a ser un cero en la posición de los
decimales y el cero de las decenas pasó
a ser cero unidades y el último cero lo
podemos tachar y moverlo a la posición
de los decimales
así que 7000 dividido entre 10 es igual
a 700 y una vez más todo lo movimos una
posición hacia la derecha de su valor
posicional entonces tenemos dos maneras
de pensar en dividir entre 10 podemos
decir que quitamos un cero a la derecha
del número o podemos decir que movemos
cada dígito una posición a la derecha de
su valor posicional
pensemos otra vez en esto en términos
del valor posicional con un número nuevo
digamos 630
si dividimos 630 entre 10 vamos a mover
todo una posición del valor posicional
hacia la derecha así que las 6 centenas
se convertirán en seis decenas las tres
decenas se convertirán en tres unidades
y las cero unidades las movemos hacia
los decimales entonces podemos decir que
630 dividido entre 10
es igual a 63 o seis decenas y tres
unidades
tenemos dos maneras de pensar al dividir
entre 10 podemos quitar un cero al final
como vemos cada uno de los dígitos una
posición de su valor posicional hacia la
derecha